This is the bone marrow, where nearly half a billion blood platelets are produced every day.
What role do these tiny platelets play in the human body?
Join the bloodstream without the fittest idea of what to do or where to go.
Be like them.
That's some kind of work for us, eh?
Young platelets, welcome to the big wide bloodstream, me lads.
Ah-ha!
Platelets?
Oh, yes, you young platelets, all right.
You may be bigger than us, but platelets shrink with age, you see.
Sir, perhaps you can tell us, do we have a purpose in life?
Of course. As collected, your job is just as important as any other part of the blood.
Be it a red corpuscle, a macrophage, or even a member of the police for a job.
I'm glad you asked that question. Now listen to me carefully.
We are responsible for the proper circulation of this entire bloodstream.
Hang about and wait for something to happen.
Oh, come on, is that quite fair?
Nothing interesting ever happened.
We lived for only ten days and the first seven have been deadly dead.
I wonder why the young policewoman told us we were useful.
We just have to be patient, I suppose.
Think of the devil, yes he is.
Hello there, old platelets.
I see you've met up with some young friends.
Welcome to the bloodstream, you newcomers,
and I hope you'll enjoy it here.
You can rely on the older fellas to show you the ropes.
Let's go. Bye for now.
To save me this.
We patch the walls.
It makes...
It is simple, actually.
Damage is caused by harmful fats, acid,
or even adrenaline when the body's had a bit of a fright.
How long do they stay there?
Forever, naturally.
Jack in the box, he's cute.
He's not cute, he's a very nasty customer of virus.
Our antibodies will get him, don't you worry.
With that, papers, please.
Can you identify yourself?
Seems to be in order.
That's very odd.
Their papers seem to be in perfect order, and yet...
There's something funny about that lot, right enough.
Let's keep an eye on them.
Sight.
Up.
Down, and I'll tell you a story about them.
One day in an earlier life, I was with a group of platelets just like you fellas.
We had no idea the disaster lay in wait for us.
Or not, the very antibodies that were supposed to protect us, attacked us instead.
What do you make of that?
What made them do it?
Thought their job was to attack outsiders, not us.
Of course, but that's when the organism is healthy.
In this case, the body was unwell.
So the antibodies attacked everyone, friend and foe.
Those rogue antibodies came to a very bad end, let me tell you.
You see, a very clever doctor worked out what was going on in the bloodstream.
So that's it. They're killing off their own platelets.
Use an old trick on them. The Trojan horse?
He injected the bloodstream with Trojan horse platelets.
They were full of medicine that killed any antibody that touched them.
Then?
Then the body was cured, of course.
We were all able to come out of hiding and get on with our normal lives.
Hello, all you platelets. Having a rest, are you?
Captain, we just heard the most unbelievably horrifying story.
Don't worry ahead about that, young fella. It doesn't happen that often.
All right, Platelet. It's time to get moving, if you don't mind.
The meaning of this. Let go.
Those enzyme cowboys with their ropes of fiber couldn't care less about the corpuscle complaints.
Misbehavior at once. It's irresponsible.
Don't be such a rotten old spoil sport.
You'll be the one to spoil the fun if you block this vein.
But there are plenty of veins.
The tissue surrounding this vein is bound to die if we can't feed it.
I don't believe you, Professor. That's just a story you made up to stop us having fun.
Stop it! Tile's top-heavy! It'll fall!
Just don't realize what you're doing. I'm going to kill off a most important part of the body.
Come on, Hemo. Pull harder. You can do it. You must.
If it's not one thing, it's another. Now, what can the latest problem be?
No, that's all we need is if we didn't have enough troubles already.
I'm calling in the Prostaglandin squad immediately.
Captain PG, I have an extremely urgent mission for you.
Clear that blockage.
Captain PG leads his specialized combat troops into action.
Only Prostaglandin can remove the blockage.
Draw your weapons, men, and fire at will.
Tough luck.
It's your turn now.
Let's see if you can do better.
I'd rather pack it in.
Anyway, I haven't got any arrows left.
So, let's go and make some.
You know I don't allow you to play with knives.
But, Mom, we only want to make some arrows.
I'll put it back in a minute.
I'll be very careful, I promise.
You've had your minute, Peter, now will you please give me that knife?
Just a second, Mum, I'm nearly finished.
Dirty knife blade were millions of germs, just waiting for an opportunity like this.
When quite incident, the body's defenses are slashed wide open.
Wonderful infection, just you wait.
What hit them?
Prepare to advance!
Lieutenant Jumbo Jr. of the Polynuclear Police.
Alert! Alert!
We've got a major emergency in our hands.
Large-scale destruction of tissue and loss of blood with a massive staphylococcus invasion.
We need combat troops and engineers to repair the damage urgently.
Don't blink it, you've come down to my size.
I see you've grown up now.
So school I was all...
Attention please, this is a general emergency.
All engineers and combat troops must report to the right thumb immediately.
Veins have been cut, body is losing blood,
and we've been invaded by a powerful force of Staphylococcus germans.
All specialized cells are ordered to step up antibody manufacture with immediate effect.
Calling all lymphocyte units, calling all lymphocyte units,
Come in, lymphocyte units, do you read me?
What we've all been waiting for.
Today, foreign agents from the Bureau of Anticoagulation.
They're behaving like absolute clots this time.
This is sheer stupidity.
What will become of us all if the...
This is mind-boggling incompetence.
What's the special force supposed to deal with them?
I'd better have a word with the foreman of the assembly line.
Your workers had me fooled for a moment.
They're loafing so hard that I almost forgot we've got a massive invasion of staff and our cockey to fight.
Mr. Foreman, do I make myself perfectly clear?
Yes, sir.
Now listen here. I want to see those antibodies coming off the line a lot faster. Get 'em, move on!
More like it.
The new genes are twisted up in spiral form, and soon they're part of a swarm of fighting antibodies.
This is still rushing to the scene of the disaster, while thrombin enzymes are collecting fibrinogen,
the basic material for the fibrin ropes used by the cowboys.
The hairs are going well, but there's still a war on.
Chips into action!
Lymphocyte is a heavyweight war machine
Hated by germs
Some anti-body support
Let's go
You, lieutenant
Very well
Ta
Those germs, no mercy, man
Those things are dangerous
Can we see your thumb?
That awful yellow stuff in my lizard
It's only pus
The dead bodies of all the white capacitors
That have been fighting germs
To keep your body healthy
Come with me
Your body produces nearly half a billion platelets every day
And now
You know what their job is
Oh, oh, oh, sorry